victoria de receptahiperdogán En esta
segunda vuelta de las elecciones en
Turquía antes justo aquí donde estamos
en la plaza icónica Plaza de taxim de
Estambul estaban habiendo bastantes
celebraciones por parte de su
simpatizantes el tiempo como estamos
viendo no acompaña por lo tanto muchos
de ellos ya se han ido hacia sus casas
aún así se podemos divisar aún algunos
coches que siguen tocando el claxon y
celebrándolo en la calle pero de forma
muchísimo más esporádica erdogan se
impone con cerca del 52% de los votos
con más de un 99%
escrutado
ambos candidatos han hablado de hecho
qué mal charolo ha dicho que ha sido un
resultado muy Injusto aún así ha seguido
Llamando a que los ciudadanos busquen la
democracia y él ha dicho que seguirá
luchando para conseguirla por su parte
ahí Perdón lo ha celebrado por todo lo
grande ha realizado discursos tanto en
Estambul como nancara en ambos sitios se
le ha podido Escuchar incluso cantando
por lo tanto he estado de total Euforia
por parte de erdogan y de su
simpatizantes
más estará en Turquía en la presidencia
hasta el año 2028